[موسيقى]
انتهن العراقي الموصلي فتحي يحيى قاسم
مهنه تصليح الاسلحه فلقب بشقمقتي وهي كلمه
عثمانيه جاءت هذه الكلمه استنادا لاصوات
الاسلحه عند فكها وضربها وفي عام
1918 قرر ان يفتتح شركته الاولى لاستيراد
الجرامافون والتلفزيون والاسطوانات في
الموصل وبعدها قرر الانتقال الى بغداد مع
ابنه عبد الله في عام
1939 افتتاح شركه خاصه بتسجيل الاغنيات
والموسيقى على الاسطوانه
[موسيقى]
طبعا عند ابويا وعند اعمامي هو ارشيف من
النوادر
لتسجيلات كلش قديمه ونادره لام كلثوم
والمطربين العراقيين القدامى
ومطربين المصريين القدامى فبقتها صار اكو
عرض قدم الى والدي هذا احكي لك بالسبعينات
ودم عرض الى والدي لشراء هذه وطبعا ما
وافق والدي على لان هذا تراث ما ممكن
نستغنى عنه ابرز الاسطوانات طبعا هو
الاغاني العراقيه اغاني العراقيه مال
الاربعينات والخمسينات والستينات
[موسيقى]
طور ابناءه شقمقشي المهنه عام
1951 بعد افتتاح استوديو وسط بغداد في
الباب الشرقي لتسجيل اغاني المطربين
العراقيين اما في القاهره فكان ابنائه
يعقدون اتفاقات مع المطربين هناك ثم تسجل
هذه الاغنيه وترسل الى السويد واليونان
ليقوموا بوضعها على اسطوانات مصنعه ومسجله
لحقوق شركه شقمقتشي
[موسيقى]
فرق من عندنا ارشيف كامل
لتسجيلات على شريط الكاسيت ومن ضمنها
تسجيلات نادره لام كلثوم وجميع المطربين
الاسطوانات كنا محتفظين بها بمكان غير
مكان الشريكه فقدرنا نحافظ عليها يعني لم
يكن
يعلم حينها انه هوايته في جمع الاسطوانات
ستجعل من اسمه اهم شريكه للتسجيلات في
العراق والحفاظ على التراث الموسيقي تعرضت
هذه التسجيلات لاعمال سلب ونهب بعد عام
2003 لكن ابناء شقمقشي حافظوا على بعض
الاسطوانات النادره وكانت مؤسسه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في العراق تستعين بها حين لا
تجد بعض المقطوعات في ارشيفها زينب المشاط
صباح العربيه بغداد